kate what's going on hi
uh thank you for taking my call hey
thank you for calling thank you for
calling it's exciting
what's up uh so just a little bit of
background i'm
27 years old and just a little over a
year ago i found out that i'm a gene
carrier for huntington's disease
huntington's is neurological it's like
als dementia alzheimer's wrapped into
one
so it's been a little it's been
something
and just according to what statistics i
have
uh because this comes from my birth
family i'm adopted so i haven't actually
seen it i don't
know um but statistically speaking
um one out of two right won't make it
yes um yeah oh you're
talking about you're talking about
passing along do you have you started
showing symptoms
no i haven't okay but um
because of it i've gone back to school
to become a social worker i started my
own business
uh and i've just been kind of trying to
plan for the future because i won't be
able to work for between five and 20
years and then i'll probably
pass on sometime in my 60s so
it's a lot so you've gone to you've gone
to scorched earth
right that's pretty much good
good for you good for you i was thinking
when you said you
are a carrier i was thinking that
you were going to ask about having kids
and at the last i looked and it's been a
minute the last i looked it was
a 50 chance of passing it on i think so
i thought that's what this call is going
you're talking about you're a carrier
and you're worried at some point this
switch gets flipped
and so you are planning for you just
found out that your neighbors have nukes
and so you are just
going to start building bomb shelters
just in case right
well part of it is having kids because i
want a family but also
i don't know how to plan for my future
if i choose to have children
whether i adopt and like how do i
prepare myself as well as my family for
that
because i have no idea so number one
that sucks
i wish i had something fancy to tell you
right now i i'm trying to put myself in
your position and
just so you know i'm laughing because i
would have done the exact same thing
i would have started writing at my my
eulogy and i would have called all my
friends together
and they would have thought i was going
to be dead by the weekend and
it would have taken a while for them to
be like oh this is a maybe
and it's 30 to 40 years what and i would
have been like i know god
so i kate i'm you and so
we're in this together i wish there was
a fancy thing i could tell you that
would make it go away and it's not right
that's a scary scary
the only thing i could think that would
be scary right is to actually
feel that first tremor or that first you
know
take that first misstep and then your
heart just sings because you know right
and then you gotta go to the doctor oh
yeah when the doctor and of course if
you're like me do you just walk through
every second of every day looking for it
um no oh you're better than me dude i
would be
oh man i mean i have moments i have some
really bad moments yeah but otherwise
i'm like okay
it's not your time you still have
between 20 and 30 years you're good
and i pray that science will catch up
and apparently finds my ketchup but i
don't know
i don't know i know but you don't have
it right
currently i do not okay i will develop
it
i want to start there okay you don't
have it
yeah so here's what i don't want you to
do
i don't i'm gonna i'm gonna oversimplify
this and i'm gonna get mean cards and
letters from the huntington's community
and it's
you're worth it okay a hundred percent
of us
don't get out of this thing alive right
yeah a hundred percent yeah um one of my
favorite psychologists
in the on planet is a psychiatrist i
guess is irving yolum
and his he came up with the idea of
existential psychology
the reason that all of us are crazy and
we build empires in families and
religions this is his
thinking is all distilled down into one
thing
because the moment we reach conscious
awareness we know that we're going to
die
and so we build all this banana stuff
like
whether it's grocery stores and roads
and we build
like all kinds of things to prop up and
lean up against this one thing and
that's we're gonna we're not gonna make
it out of here
and so yeah i don't what you are
experiencing
is that 100x right because you have a
path now most of us don't know
we don't know we just go through our day
thinking it's going to be around 85.
really in our heads we think it's gonna
be about 106. right
but it's we can look at the data you've
got a different picture in front of you
right so yeah i want to back out and i i
want to start
with this premise don't let
tomorrow's future pain steal your joy
from today
and you have a different level than most
of us right so i'm not i want to
minimize what you're experiencing
at the same time every joyful second is
precious to you right
yes it is and the more you run out into
the future and pick up
cinderblocks to run back into the
present and carry with you around every
day
the more you're just going to suck the
soul out of these precious moments that
you do have
and so there is a real
need for you to plan financially right a
real need
there is a real need for you to you're
going to have some hard roads to go with
life insurance and with any sort of
insurance and things like that right so
instead of opening your own business you
may work for
a company that's going to have great
health insurance because you know down
the road
those are the kind of decisions that i
want you to get with a doctor
not a not the internet for god's sake
never go on the internet again
kate ever right there's a phenomenal
doctor here in madison
so i'm all connected with that that is a
doctor that's going to walk with you
i want you to find a huntington's
community and that may actually have to
be on the internets but people who have
walked this line
with you and are going to humanize the
internet drama
right and there will be real people
hopefully it could be people you could
meet with in person you could go have
coffee with some folks and
meet with their family i want you to not
carry any heavier brick than you've got
to does that make sense
and yeah the internet has a vested
interest in making these bricks as heavy
as possible so you'll keep clicking
i want you to actually go make eye
contact with people even if you got to
fly somewhere
make eye contact with folks who have
experienced this who are experiencing it
family members and
really get a real picture on it does
that make sense
yeah and then you're going to have to
have some hard conversations with your
current family with who
with your significant other right
on what family is going to look like do
you adopt do you
want to roll the dice and have kids no
one can tell you that but you
and so you're in it and it sucks
and your moments
your seconds your relationships got a
thousand times
more precious and so
do your best to get facts and data
do your best to not live way into the
future
and those are gonna happen they're like
lightning bolts they shoot into your
mind
and you go nope that's later that's a
problem for future kate
because today kate is gonna is going to
burn
all the tread off these tires right he's
going to have as many fun adventures
he's going to
do incredible meaningful work is going
to sit with folks do the things that
bring you joy
and begin to make meaning of this thing
but none of us get out of here and i
hope your story kate
is a is a magical story for everybody
because none of us know right none of us
know
life is a mist and a vapor and it goes
so fast
so so fast every second is precious
every second is precious kate thank you
for that call i know that's tough i know
that's tough i know that's tough
and we'll be thinking about you get
connected with your
doctor community people and live in the
present